nv energy is empowering the future
leaders of tomorrow by supporting youth
education in our communities angel
williams is the community relations
manager for envy energy she joins us to
talk about some of the great things envy
energy foundation is doing thanks for
being here today thank you for having me
and you guys really do a lot including
um an array of scholarships yeah we're
excited to launch our powerful
partnership scholarship program right
now we've had a 20-year history of
operating that scholarship program
it's awarded to eligible graduating high
school seniors
that are applying to a school in nevada
nevada system of higher education school
we're prioritizing students that have
had community service and volunteerism
that 3.0 weighted gpa those students are
qualified to apply for this scholarship
program so if somebody's watching this
now and has a student that would qualify
what should they do visit our website
scholarship there you'll find all the
details how to qualify how to apply our
partners the public education foundation
with the scholarship program and they've
been that long-term partner for us over
20 years like i mentioned we've had
a long history in that 20 years we've
awarded two million dollars in
scholarships statewide to 2000 students
so it certainly made an impact for
families and students it is incredibly
impressive i host that luncheon every
year for the scholarships and
there are it seems like pages and pages
of nv energy recipients
the generosity is is on display for sure
it's been transformational for a lot of
students and families you know i think
the fact that we're able to award the
scholarship to a graduating
high schooler in nevada and then send
them on to that post-secondary
experience in college in nevada
hopefully they're you know finding jobs
and staying here we've got that cultural
competence that's built in that's so
important for our community and and so
we're excited to be able to support the
students and families that way and
that's just one aspect of what the envy
energy foundation is doing a lot of it
is though focused on education it is and
we also prioritize outreach to diverse
communities
we're proud to have supported a number
of organizations some of the highlights
and diverse communities for us would be
an educational fund that we provide with
the moapa band of paiutes that fund
provides for educational resources and
access to education and achievement for
those students from that tribal
community another favorite of mine is
what the uplift foundation that
organization puts on their youth and
justice forum every year really
connecting youth to understanding what
their civic rights are
and understanding
interactions with law enforcement so
great program what i also love is the
effort to diversify stem education and
you guys are a big part of that as well
we are yeah we've been proud to fund a
stem robotics program at the girls
athletic leadership school it's a local
charter school here that specializes in
serving
all girls in that middle school age
range such an important age to get girls
interested in science yeah love it angel
thank you so much for being here and
thank uh big thanks to envy energy
foundation for all the great work really
appreciate it we want to thank nv energy
for sponsoring this segment you can
still apply as we were talking about for
the nv energy powerful partnership
scholarship
online through february 13th just visit
nvenergy.com forward slash scholarship